It goes back to the basic idea of
why are we studying a language?
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and today
I wanna talk about what is the most
important thing in language learning?
The most important thing
in language learning.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
So what's important in language learning?
The answer is quite simple.
What is important in language is whatever
is important to you, the learner.
All right.
And I'll explain what I mean by that
you'll remember, or those of you who
follow me will remember the three keys
to language earning, which I often refer
to something that I heard at a language
teachers conference in San Diego many
years ago, and a very experienced person
with many years of teaching told me that
there are only three things that matter
in language learning: the attitude of the
learner, the time spent with the language,
not reading grammar in your native
language but actually with the language
listening, reading, speaking, writing.
And the third thing is
the ability to notice.
And that is a little more difficult
to understand, but if we do research
on things that we notice in life, we
notice things that are important to us.
And so the importance of things becomes
a big factor in language acquisition.
And I, I thought of doing this
video because I noticed that I was
listening to a mini story in Persian
for the, I don't know, 30th time and
I noticed something about verbs in
or particular, a particular verb in
Persian that I hadn't noticed before.
Why did I notice it?
I didn't deliberately sort of plan
to notice that, but probably in the
sort of evolution of my learning
of Persian, I'm now sort of open to
noticing something which has now become
important to me because I noticed
that I'm struggling with certain, you
know, patterns of verbs in Persian.
And so then I noticed this
thing in, in this story.
It's not that I set out, you know,
I'm gonna listen to this story
and I'm gonna deliberately notice
the verbs or something like that.
No, it's just that I was ready to
notice this particular verb and
structure and having noticed it there.
And I'll probably notice it again.
I think we've all had the experience
that once you notice something
somewhere, you'll notice in other places.
And eventually then hopefully that
then becomes a pattern that I will
recognize and that I'll be able to
use, but it begins with the idea
that this now is important for me.
Uh, you know, I remember when I was
learning Chinese characters and of
course teachers like to teach you
things that they think are important.
So the teacher decides what's important.
So they taught me that the Chinese
characters have these radicals,
these components that represent
either meaning or in many cases,
the sound of the character, but it
made no, you know, impression on me.
I couldn't really recognize them.
It didn't really help
me learn the characters.
I still felt that I had to learn
each character individually.
Much, much later I began to see
the importance of these radicals or
components in the Chinese charact.
It's like, uh, you know, the teacher,
again, I've, I've mentioned this before,
people who, um, write, uh, textbooks
for languages, feel that they, they
wanna start with in, in some, in many
languages, relatives, you know, your uncle
on your mother's side, on your father's
side, your older sister, your younger
sister, they all have different names.
And so people want to teach
this to you right up front.
And I always find that this is like
of no interest to me at this point.
It's not important to me.
There's so many other things that
I need to learn about the language
that this simply is not important.
Uh, textbooks like to
introduce festivals to you.
Again, it may be important to some
beginners, not important to me.
At a later stage in my learning
I will find those things very
interesting and therefore important.
Um, you know, some textbooks like
to teach you all the colors at once.
It's not important to me and
therefore I can't learn them when a
particular color becomes important.
I will notice it and I will learn it.
Um, you know, I was thinking too, it's
a bit like, uh, when we drive a car,
uh, if we approach an intersection,
um, I now as a driver with many, many
years of experience, I'm looking for
cars that might be coming from the
right hand side or the left hand side.
Maybe they aren't, maybe they're
gonna run the intersection.
Uh I'll notice, for example, if I'm
gonna turn right on a red light,
which I'm allowed to do, uh, are
there pedestrians crossing or
attempting to cross the intersection?
There's so many things that I naturally
notice that are important to me.
At an early stage as a driver, when I'm
struggling with my manual gear shift or
other things in the car that are more
important to me, I don't notice these
things, or I might notice from the car
that there's a new restaurant, that's
just opened up in my, uh, area of town.
And I'll notice a restaurant, but I
won't notice, for example, a nail salon,
because I'm not interested in nail
salons, but I'm interested in restaurants.
Restaurants are important to me.
It goes back to the basic idea
of why are we studying a language
if learning that language is not
important to you, you won't learn.
Uh, if the time you spend trying
to learn that language is not an
important use of time, you won't learn.
Uh, the more you can seek out a
content of interest content that
is important to you to learn from
the better you're gonna learn.
Um, if there are issues of grammar that
are important to you, you so important
that you actually Google for them, or
look through a grammar book and look them.
Uh, at a time when they are important to
you, you're more likely to learn them.
If the teacher decides, okay, class
today, we're gonna learn the subjunctive
and you are struggling with so many
other things in the language that this
explanation of the subjunctive makes
no impression on you, because you're
not ready to receive that information.
You don't have other relevant information
or knowledge to make it more meaningful.
It's not important to you.
So there are so many ways in which
what's important in language learning
is what's important to us, whether it
be in terms of the, the language content
that we learn from, or the aspects of
the language that we wanna learn about,
or simply the fact that a natural
process of, you know, having more and
more pieces of the jigsaw puzzle of that
language have been put on the board.
And so now you are able to
focus on the missing pieces.
These missing pieces are
now important to you.
So, uh, I think the ability to, to, to
notice, uh, because we notice things that
are important to us, it's it's in many
ways, a subconscious uh, process, but
at the same time, you have to be open.
You ha...
you're not gonna notice things if you're
not open, uh, open to new, um, sights and
sounds, open to new ways of pronouncing
things open to new ways of saying things.
If you are open to these things and
the language is important to you,
gradually more and more aspects of
that language will become important.
You will acquire, initially passively,
and then eventually you'll be able
to use them, uh, when speaking.
So, uh, I'll leave you with a video
that I did about, um, you know, the
noticing hypothesis, which, uh, is
part of the sort of linguistics world
explaining how we learn and also an
old video on the importance of choosing
content of interest to learn from.
So thank you for listening.
Bye for now.